Welcome to ICT for dummies
All right guys, wait, what episode are we on time bro? Yeah, it's fucking dude. I grew up had kids
died came back to life and
Now we're starting to do GTA 6 is about to come out. Yeah
No, genuinely. This is like from the bottom of my heart our hearts. We are so so sorry
And the reality is that we didn't stop the series because we didn't want to finish it, but we just realized
that we hadn't shown you a lot of like our lives outside of trading and
You know
We wanted to just show you a little bit of other shit that goes on in our life because I don't want it to just be
Trading related, but now we're gonna push out this entire series. It's gonna be fucking insane. What the fuck are you doing, bro?
Actually, I'm the fucking
And this is about to be the sauciest shit the world has ever seen literally the sauciest
Series the world has ever seen. I mean, it's already been super saucy, you know, we're underrated but it's fine
You're not gonna find something that explains these concepts as well as we do. Anyways, let's spin back that intro
Welcome to ICT for dummies episode 10
daily bias
Daily bias. Yeah, I'm rolling hella deep. I feel like a damn daily bias
Bitch, I'm gonna hell. Hey, yo
Yeah, chill on me chat. Um, I let's run this bitch up. So
Whoa, and today guys, whoa, we are going to be covering daily bias
Like Pat said this is going to be probably like the sauciest episode we have ever recorded
Yeah, definitely the sauciest episode we ever recorded. It's going to be going over drawn liquidity and how I find my bias every day
We're gonna first get into why the market is moving get into the two ways to actually find your bias and drawn liquidity and the five
Questions that you have to be asking yourself
Or really like three questions you have to be asking yourself and that's how you'll find your drawn liquidity
And then from there, you know, I'll show you guys some drawings and then we'll get into some chart examples
Oh drawing drawn liquidity. That's a lit if I've ever heard of lit super cool. Super cool
Can we move our face cam to the right because it's gonna be covering the minute time frames and shit
They're gonna need to know what time frame around so it's better. So I'm sure it is
Yeah, they don't have to know the minute time. Yeah, they do because if I'm like I'm going on the hourly chart right now
They need another run the hourly chart. So let's move it over to the right side. I know it's not usual
But I don't feel comfortable right now. Yeah, I'm not gonna run the right side now. So
Let's get into this. All right. So first off guys again, like we're
Let's get into this. All right. So why does the market move?
Okay, so when you're finding your bias for the day, you have to be asking yourself
Why is the market even moving in the first place, right?
First off we can we can see here we have rebalance inefficiencies
So an inefficiency is simply just a fair value gap and price likes to trade back towards bullish for value gaps and bearish for value
Gaps and this gives people a better entry right a better entry in price
So you're not just entering off of a really high
Premium right when you get these large gaps up price likes to rebalance into these ranges and into these fair value gaps
Do you then send price higher? Okay
Does the size of the gap matter the size of the gap does not matter. Thank God. Yeah. All right, you good
Yeah, okay, just double checking because I was sound like something else. I don't know. It's good. Anyways next up similar. Oops
Just shake it a little bit more pal. No, keep going. I'll hold it for you the entire time. Actually. I'm good
I don't I don't like touching the desk. Okay next up. We have rebalanced to equilibrium. Okay, so
Similar to inefficiencies, but this time it's going to be when we have a really fat range
So I'll show you guys an example soon
But when we have a really big impulse leg where the market just shoots up or just dumps, right?
We're gonna have a big range that price likes to rebalance you right again. People don't want to be shorting in a
Discount for example here, right in this scenario
We want to be shorting in a premium and then and when we're longing people don't want to be longing in a premium people
Want to be longing in a discount, right? We already went over this and our premium and discount video
So if you haven't seen that already, please go watch that because it's gonna explain a lot and you definitely need to be watching this
that video first and
finally
Price likes to move and price does move to seek liquidity
Okay, and we had a whole entire two-part series already on seeking liquidity
So go watch that and it went over all the liquidity pools
So we have you know buy side sell side day side day side, right?
And pretty much all the problems I find there's no that there's no side side buy side sell side
There should be some side side because when the market's just chopping your side side, that's gas
Yeah, super guys eating the side liquidity super gas and
But but yeah, I got we already went over all the different types of liquidity pool
So the prominent ones that you guys should be remembering is like previous day high previous day low session liquidity
You know any time-based liquidity is really gonna be important
Also equal highs equal lows
Low resistance liquidity as targets, right and
honestly, we can
Move on right. This is pretty much all you guys really need to be asking yourself is why is the market moving and
Where the drawn liquidity is? Okay, so so yeah
I mean, this is really the three main aspects of the market and if you can understand these then
You've practically mastered the markets
But yeah now let's get into how do you find your drawn liquidity your DOL your BBL
so
You ask yourself. Are we delivering from buy side or?
Are we delivering from
Sell side, right? So Blake tell me here. What do you think is happening on the left side? Okay, so wrong
So here we're delivering from sell side you can see that right here price comes down
It's sweep some sell side and we're not displacing below the sell side
We're delivering from the sell side and in the process of that
Obviously as we were delivering towards the sell side
We created probably bearish fair value gaps
And so then after we deliver up from sweeping the sell side we start invalidating this bearish for value gap
And now we are respecting bullish PDR raise. So in
summary, wow
We are delivering from sell side
We are disrespecting bearish PDR raise and we are respecting bullish PDR raise, right?
So these are the two questions you need to ask yourself
Are we delivering from buy side or sell side and what PDR raise are we respecting versus disrespecting forgot to say that before and here?
We're delivering from sell side. We're disrespecting bearish PDR raise and respecting bullish PDR raise, right?
And all this is in the process of delivering to some sort of drawn liquidity
Which blaked marked out with this zesty eyeball
All right
If you ever see those tiktokers putting eyeballs at their drawn liquidity, just know that they've never gotten to pay out
True. Very true. Now on the right side. We have the vice
Versa here. We're delivering from buy side because you can see that price comes down. It comes up
It sweeps this buy side and now we start getting bearish order flow here
We're disrespecting bullish and respecting bearish and we're delivering towards that drawn liquidity, which it can be seen here with this eyeball
We don't know what this mysterious drawn liquidity is
But you know, just know that if someone has an eyeball there, they're probably hitting a 1 to 20 rr
And it's a first one they've had in nine months
True that. Yeah. So yeah guys, these are the questions that you should be asking yourself. So every day when I'm coming into my day
I don't know when I'm coming into the day every day
There's no good way says what I'm looking at my daily bias, I'm trying to find my daily bias
When I'm trying to find my daily bias, I'm asking myself these questions first question
I'm asking myself is are we delivering from bias at our sell side first?
I just want to see that's what are we generally doing right and then from there
I'm looking at what PD rays are we respecting versus disrespecting and then finally I'm really just asking myself
Why should the market even be moving here? Right? Are we going to rebalance towards the range?
Are we going to be seeking out some sort of liquidity? Are we running stop losses, right? Or are we going to be?
Trading into some sort of inefficiency, right?
Because the market is always moving for those three reasons and to find out if the market is going to go there
you first need to see if we're delivering from bias at our sell side and then you need to see if we are respecting or
disrespecting these PD arrays and
Yeah, I mean from here. This is just literally just drawings, right?
And I'll show you guys now some chart examples that I send out every single day in our premium and discord
I send out a daily bias and I basically just call the market live in front of everyone
So I'll show you guys what that looks like
And I'll put on
My speedy glasses for this one, baby. Oh, wait, you actually look hella aura. This should be the thumbnail
May not
Hey, wait one more time smiling
Wait, I don't like my smile like a device right here. Yeah, it's hard. I just like this, right? Oh
That's fine. That's fine. All right
Walk the fuck in walk the fuck in. Oh my god. All right
All right guys, so gonna get into this so starting off. I want to start with this day. So this was
This was on the 7-2-2-25 second 20-25, okay, so I said on this day I had a bullet coming into the morning
We saw previous day low then hear me a low inside this daily busy and we're only displacing higher
Sorry, and we if we get this 15-minute hourly CISD we can expect London highs and a recent buy side
Internal liquidity pools we have data highs obvious draw and I want to see that get hit. Okay, by the way
I just want to say if this sounds like complete Chinese to you. Yeah, definitely rewatch some of our videos because here
We're talking a lot about basic liquidity
Previous a low, you know being the previous day's lowest point internal low is gonna be that
internal low of your current trading leg and then daily busy think of that as just a
Bullish fair value gap, right? That's usually what we're referring to if we say daily busy. So like a daily bullish for value gap
And a Siby is a bearish for value up. Yeah, so it's really sometimes it just matters how zesty you're feeling
Which term you want to use but fair value gap?
like bearish for value gap Siby bullish for value gap busy
Buy side and balance versus sell side. Yeah all that shit and then
CISD well
Yes, you just change and say delivery. So it's the same thing here with like this market structure shift
You're seeing it's just a change in order flow, right?
We're changing delivery here when we start displacing through these Peter is we start now respecting these Peter is okay
I wouldn't we would make a video on CIC, but I really don't think it's that important
Maybe we'll chef it up later down the line. But yeah, I think I'm just like a market structure shift
Yeah, so from here guys, I'll show you what this looks like on the charts, right?
So we have a sweep of free state low and then we are delivering from here and we are
Disrespecting these Peter is right and then we have clear internal targets. Okay, so the questions I'm asking myself, right?
Number one, why would the market even be moving in this scenario? Okay. Well as you can see here, we have data highs resting
Okay, so what is this? This is a liquidity pool, right?
We went over this in our liquidity part two video of different types of liquidity pools
Data highs is a really really strong draw on liquidity
So this is going to be a great reason for the market to be moving here
Also, what do we have very prominent buy side liquidity and relative equal highs here, right?
So these these stacked up highs is going to be a very strong draw as well
Okay, so two reasons for the market be moving first being this external buy side liquidity here
And then also we have data highs here on the internal time frame being the reason that the market could be moving. Okay now
Next question. I'm gonna be asking myself that I how I actually found this bias is where are we delivering from?
Are we doing from buy side or sell side here? We are delivering from sell side, right being previous day low nice
All right, so we're delivering from sell side and then what Peter is are we respecting versus disrespecting?
Well, we are currently disrespecting this bearish PDR right here
And we are going to be most likely respecting these bullish PDRs. We can assume that
and
That's what I said, and we're just displacing high right and then as you can see here
Show you guys the result after we get that change to delivery. This was an order block
I mean we just got a close above this
You can also use a one-minute inverse for reference here. We had a tiny one-minute inverse here, which is usually what we use
Literally right about 15 minute time frame. I was a 15 minute time frame. Okay
Well, even if we're using inversions, you can see that if you don't want to use like a 15-minute CISD
which I mean to be honest we use inversions to determine flips in order flow unless
Price isn't giving us any inversions because price is choppier on the day
Then you can usually refer to like a CISD but inversions work amazing for confirming a flip in order flow
So right we've been bearish for a while we take our previous a low
So we're delivering from sell side here and then you can see that we start invalidating these bearish 15-minute for value gaps
They're small, but they're there and so that means we're now disrespecting bearish PDRs
Right, and we're gonna start respecting bullish PDRs
And of course, what are we gonna be delivering towards that drawn liquidity that buy set up there? So we're seeking liquidity after
After seeking liquidity
Right exactly after the living from that sell side and now we're seeking more liquidity
Beautiful. All right, that's a bias there
So this is another daily bias
Where I said, you know, I was leaning bullish. This was a more of a condition based day. I explained conditions
Yeah, I mean so
Really when we say it's a condition based day
I mean like here we'll read out the bias first. So Blake said I'm leaning bullish coming into the day nearing all-time highs
Ideal scenario coming into the morning would be for 930 to open lower trading into the 4-hour bullish for a value gap and taking out
London lows then getting lower time frame long out of that
So what that would look like is if we want to take longs
Then we want to see price retrace lower into that 4-hour bullish for value gap and then we want to see that 4-hour get
respected also if we hit that 4-hour we
Simultaneously be sweeping London lows and then a long out of that would look like a clean
You know inversion in the 1 to 5 minute time frame towards the upside confirming that narrative
So this gap is what we call condition because if we end up breaking it and by breaking it
We usually mean if we end up inversing it we're expecting price to displace lower now. It's always like
When you have a condition there actually needs to be a reason for why price could go in either direction
So we know here that if price respects this 4-hour bullish for value gap
Then we have a reason to be bullish and we have a reason to look for longs
Because we know that there's resting buy set up here that we can take and overall we're in an all-time highs narrative, right?
During all-time highs trading I your ideal scenarios to catch some sort of long because you can typically get better moves
But just because we're at all-time highs doesn't mean doesn't mean we have to keep ripping higher
So we set a condition like this this 4-hour condition if price invalidates it or starts running through it
Then can we expect lower prices?
Yes, why because we have sell side resting below that we can target so there would be a reason if
Prices and have a reason to go in a certain direction
Don't just try to force a trade in that direction and that's a mistake. A lot of people make
And so that sell side would be like previous day low and then there's like a daily fair value gap below as well
So you know this end up ripping this day. Yeah, all-time highs
Yeah, so that's just like an example of how we would trade condition based on the higher time frame and as you can
Yeah, so as you can see I
Mean being that we're all-time highs. What do you think is gonna be the most probable scenario? We respect that for our
Bullish value gap and we end up ripping higher and seeking that liquidity above what happens price trace
Retraces lower into that for our bullish value gap that gets respected. We end up seeking that buy side
Oh, wait, sorry in this day actually. Oh, yeah, we did end up in our hour
Yeah, that candle ended up hitting and then the next one that ended up delivering higher
But yeah, I mean now if you're watching this we're
Resting most likely near all-time highs conditions and we probably will be for maybe a few months
So just make sure that when you are really not a few months, man
Maybe not that long
But just if you're ever trading all-time highs and you're too premiumed to be like really looking for a long
Wait for a high time frame pullback into a key level like a four-hour bullish value gap an hourly bullish value gap
And then if that gets respected, you know, you're confirming that narrative that price wants to go higher. Yeah
Yeah, so let's keep going into examples
I know it's gonna might seem annoying
But I want to literally ingrain this into your guys's brains to the point where you want to kill me. Okay
No one would ever want to kill you. Thanks, bro. So on this day
This was another you know, we're always having and setting ourselves conditions, right and every time I'm coming into my morning
I have if then savings, right?
so if I if this happens then I will do this right and
When I what I want you guys to do when you're building your bias as well is to always be leaning somewhere
So as you can see, I'm always leaning somewhere, but I'm never going to be married to a bias. It's very rarely
I'll be married to a bias except for like very obvious days. Like I think on the first example
I showed you I was very married to this bias
I didn't even set myself a condition to be bearish because it just there was no reason to
but a lot of the times I am going to be
Having some sort of condition to be seen either way now
That being said on this day. I said I was leaning bullish, right? We have a new week opening gap lower though
And in SMT with the spice of liquidity
So condition is this 15 minute back gap if we break it expect the lower resistance the query in the new week opening
Gap to get hit if we hold it. I'll expect price to keep trading higher obvious stall on the query right now for yes
Okay, so what I'm looking at this day, right? I can see that we're very obviously trending towards this buy side
Okay, I thought you're gonna shoot me something right and
What I want you guys to know is that you really don't need to be like
Over complicating your bias that much in the sense that you can very clearly see that we're just trending up, right?
We're very clearly going towards a liquidity pool being this buy side liquidity right here, right?
So just be bullish until them, right and from here
So I was saying right we have yes as a very obvious straw here
Alright, so the condition was this 15 minute gap, right?
We can go up hit this buy side, right?
Because that's the obvious draw right now and then from there this gap will be the condition, right?
What does that mean?
Once we go up here if we trade lower and respect this where can price go keep going higher if we hit this high
Trade lower disrespect this gap then where can price go down towards this low resistance liquidity in the new week opening gap
Okay, so
Overall going back to this. Why would the market even be moving here, right?
So it can move higher for one for for a reason like this to seek buy side liquidity
And then it can move lower to not only seek liquidity being this low resistance liquidity that we have here
But also to rebalance this inefficiency being this new day opening gap, right?
And then the next questions we're asking ourselves is how do I actually find my draw, right?
So are we delivering from buy side or sell side in this scenario?
We would be delivering from buy side, right?
If we hit this high first and then are we going to be respecting or disrespecting Peter race?
Well, we'll just have to see right if we disrespect this Peter a then it's very likely
We will go seek this liquidity and go rebalance towards this inefficiency
All right. So as you can see here, we end up trading higher hitting this buy side liquidity
We end up disrespecting this for Valley Gap
This was our condition that we set for ourselves to be bullish and also to be bearish, right?
We disrespect this and then we trade back higher and then we trade back up to this order block CSD
This inversion for Valley Gap gets respected and then we trade lower down towards this new day opening gap that we left for ourselves
And also simultaneously taking out all of this low resistance liquidity. So
Again guys, very very simple
But I want you to literally be asking yourself these questions every single time before you're entered before you're writing out your daily bias
Right. Why is the market moving here? Ask yourself that then ask yourself
Are we delivering from buy side or sell side and what Peter is are you respecting or disrespecting? Okay
and
That's really how you'll find your bias. Okay, and I'll show this one
This was a little bit more of a complicated bias and I'll talk about this because this was a little bit more discretionary
I keep shaking the fucking camera because this bias I sent out was a little bit more discretionary
Okay, and we have a like five more examples. So I'm just gonna do this one really quick. Okay
Now I said on this day
I had a neutral bias and I really want to show this because I think this is an important bias
But we have a neutral bias
We have an SMT with previous day high and a huge range from tariff news yesterday
So I can expect today to rebalance yesterday's range towards equilibrium right now we have an SMT with this four-hour
So I want to see if that holds if this holds expect previous day high to get it if this SMT gets ran through
Expect the unfilled 15-minute gap in equilibrium yesterday's range massive movie yesterday
So most likely chop your conditions for today's AM session be cautious
Okay, so with conditions guys, it doesn't always have to be Peter is right doesn't always have to be for value
Doesn't always have to be okay if this 15-minute gap gets ran through if this hourly gets ran through if this hourly holds or
Gets ran through right it can also be with SMTs, which is what I like to do a lot of the time
For example here, right we have this SMT. So if I were to be bullish on this day
I really want to see this SMT hold right? I want to see this whole
I do not want to see this get traded through
I would want this to be the lowest point in which price wants to go
However, if this SMT does decide to get ran through and if we want to start trading through London lows, then what can you expect?
Well, we have this inefficiency here, right?
So the market would be moving to rebalance an inefficiency being the unfilled 15-minute for value gap and also to rebalance where?
Equilibrium of this range, right? We have a very very large impulse move up and this is a fat range from tariff news
So price was will most likely rebalance this range if this SMT here gets invalidated
Okay, and I don't have a photo from my chart, but I went back on this day and showed it
Let me just say this is practically like when the market gives you a really big Drake candle
It needs to have a slight retracement lower so it can pop a honey pack and then give you another Drake
Facts Wow, that was really good that me up fire you trade. No, do you know what are we talking about right now?
I don't know. I thought we were talking about real estate. Yeah. Yeah, it's like my house is so low
Yeah, right. I think you don't want to buy a house in a premium
But yeah guys, that's how I was able to freelance brand scale for free
I don't know if you guys want more sauce on that. But as you can see here
I don't know why Pat had this in his um thing. It's it's like reverse psychology, right?
Like this was this was back then like this is near this is over a year ago guys
And so we are at all-time lows. Yeah, and I and I wanted to stay humble
I didn't want to scare my competitors by saying I'm the best trader ever. We do we are the best live traders
No, I kept it a humble abode said we were the worst discord. So nobody would join we could gatekeep it
But then the community got kind of freaky and they started sending freaky AI pictures of us
So yeah, I had to delete it because now it's no more. Yeah, we're psychology. No, it's real. Yep
Okay, and then as you can see you guys we end up
disrespecting this SMT here and it was at this point where I flipped bias to down here and towards this and we did catch a
Short this day towards this unfiltered human gap and towards this pretty much all of these days
Like when my bias just plays out perfectly
it's it's really nice because I'm able to go on the lower time frame and have that confirmation and
again, like you're finding basically every single day where the market is moving and on the lower time frame you're doing the
exact same thing and
Then this one was just a lot of aura points on this day
I mean this was pretty like a pretty simple right right like we're delivering from by side
You can explain just explain this one
What yeah, I mean, so this is a pretty simple day because here we have that higher time frame condition
being that for our bullish gap and
We're delivering from by side, right?
So here price seeks liquidity and you can see that because what do you notice price was super bearish, right?
Even if we look before this we had we had a really strong impulse candle down
So when we have that we can expect price to what rebalance this unfilled gap above we had this unfilled for our
Price does that but then it decides I'm gonna disrespect this Petey Ray and when that's when that gets disrespected
Then we open up a bullish Petey race. Now, we're disrespecting bearish respecting bullish
It respects this four-hour and seeks liquidity takes out previous day high now that we've taken out previous day high
We're gonna set this four hours of condition and say if we disrespect this for our bullish gap
We can expect we can expect price to go lower and seek this sell side
And as you can see in versus that four-hour seeks sell side
But I have a chino in my mouth right now. So I sound like orangey, but shout out orangey. That's a fucking goat
I love you. I want to pay for now with him
You shouldn't we should we should live together orangey imagine I think he commented that or so really
Oh, I want to live with or I think you commented that he has he has this
$5,000 machine that cools his bed to whatever temperature. Yeah, no way insane. Yeah insane
Here speak for a second. I need a poop
That shit. So again guys in this scenario, let's just run over it right the let's just
Go through the mind of what I was thinking here, right? Why would the market be moving here to seek liquidity, right?
We have a really nice sell side amount sell side liquidity pool right here, right?
Now, how do I actually find that? Well, we're delivering from buy side being previously high. It was just a fart and then
we are
disrespecting bullish PDR is meaning what right we're delivering from my side disrespecting bullish literally bar for bar
We have drawn out. Yeah, so it's very very simple guys. Don't over complicate this. Just ask yourself these questions and
This is another pretty simple glass. Yeah, so then a bias going into this morning. This is back in January
We said going to continue being bearish coming into the morning
I'm not gooning in the morning
There are still lower targets on NQ and ES
We're still in a higher time frame so model towards previous week low
So we have previous week low below to continue being bearish. I would need to see EQ of the range respect that open
So here since we had a super strong impulse candle down
we want to see price rebalance EQ to deliver lower right rebounds a range and then seek that liquidity and so
Then you can see and guys again, don't over complicate this like it's very obvious that we're just trending lower, right?
and this is
Gonna sound corny but trade with the trend like the trend is your friend
I know it sounds corny, but this is way too often
I see people trying to trade against the trend and trying to catch all these reversals
That also doesn't mean you're a trendline trader
By the way
Yeah
Rating with the trend because you're still gonna be looking for those lower time frame confluences of price rebalancing a range on the lower time
Frame confirming that you know narrative that you want to go lower
So even if we're trading we're trending lower you still want to see on a lower time frame a pull back into a five or
15 minute and get your inversion from there. Yeah, also
With this I was saying when I was talking about like EQ getting respected. This is also a condition, right?
so the same way we can have conditions with like
For example if a rally gap same way we can have conditions with an SMT
I said I want to see get hold EQ of a range is also an area where you want to see get hold
right and you do not want to see
price trading higher than like this golden pocket here really because if we start
Trading this deep into discount most likely we are going to go to the next time
Okay, you do not want to see big big pullbacks like all the way up here
Okay, so you want to see price respect equilibrium and
Trade into discount and then bounce from there and then on this day
You know trading to that you can see that we ended up respecting equilibrium perfectly and we ended up trading all the way down to
previous week low
bang bang beautiful
Yeah, another day here. We have also January bearish buys coming into the day respecting this one hour unicorn
What does that mean? Just a fair value gap in a breaker block overlapped
And we are in bearish order flow on the higher time frame
I'm looking to see us have an open high low close at 930 sweeping out the 15-minute internal high to then trade lower with
Us generating this trendline liquidity on the lower time frame these stacked lows are the drawn liquidity for today so you can see
Since we're stacking up a bunch of lows here
I mean we're respecting this hourly bearish PDR and we have all these stacked lows below
So ideally we'd want to see nine. I mean this is just our ideal scenario
We want to see 930 open higher so we can get a premium short to run this lower resistance liquidity and
As you can see eventually price respects this bearish hourly fair value gap
And we run all this over this liquidity resting down here
Yeah
This was a really fun day to trade because it did exactly what I wanted it to do right we have and again the questions
You guys have to be asking yourself, right?
Why would the market be moving here to seek liquidity, right?
What liquidity pools we have low resistance liquidity we went over that and then relative equal lows this stacks liquidity, right?
This accumulation right here. Okay, then the next question. Are we delivering from buy side or sell side?
We're delivering from where Asia highs, right?
So we're delivering from this buy side and then are we respecting or disrespecting Peter is well
We are disrespecting this bullish gap
There was a little bullish gap here that got disrespected and then what are we doing?
We are respecting this bearish gap right here. So respecting bullish
Disrespecting bearish, okay, or sorry disrespecting bullish. Excuse me disrespecting bullish
respecting bearish on this day
Okay, and it would now make sense for place to go lower and on this day again
I was saying is really fun to trade because we did end up having like my perfect ideal scenario that I said I wanted to
see happen where we trade higher take out this internal high and then went run lower and
As you can see we went higher took out this internal high on the one-hour time frame
And then we caught up pretty nasty short on this day
Targeting that low
So this was a nasty day. I remember this but um
Yeah, so this is gonna be like the final example that I want to show you guys
This was on a day where I was not able to trade live and I was just talking about the bias
Basically just through my phone and I want to show you guys how I go about finding not only my bias
But also my entry model so so this is gonna teach you a lot about like time frame alignment because like we said the bias
Is important and all you can have the right bias
but this is what I always tell people and I made a video on take talk about this recently like
Knowing where price wants to go is important
But knowing how price is going to get there is far more important remember because you're not executing on the four-hour time for me
I actually get on the one-hour time frame
You guys are future traders
most of you are trading on funded accounts meaning your
Executions are gonna happen between the one to five minute chart and your trades typically don't last more than 20 30 minutes
you know what I mean, so in order to confirm a bias we need that lower time frame confirmation and
We do this by utilizing stuff like conditions and that's what the next video is gonna be on you guys are gonna fucking love that video
It's truly like one of the best lessons
And that's how you confirm a bias with a lower time frame drawn liquidity as well
And then you get your entry, but yeah, but I can get into this. Yeah, so
On this day, I did have a bullish bias right
Reasoning for this was because the market would be moving in the scenario to rebalance and inefficiency, right?
We had an unfilled unmitigated gap and we were delivering from where sell side liquidity
So we should go up higher to rebalance this range, right?
And I said I want to see this trade up to this this Delos mark. We have a neck model
Okay, we're getting some models and all that later
But we end up having a S&T here, right and price does end up eventually trading towards this
15-minute gap here as you can see so from here, right?
We have another scenario where we can kind of have this be our you know bias setter, right?
Where if we want to see this get respected, it's all if then statements, right?
If this gets respected, they should then send us higher to this by sell liquidity
However, if this gets disrespected this could send us lower
Okay, and I did say I was expecting this to hold to send us higher because I was overall bullish on the day
so I said I was expecting this whole sense higher and
That's what I told everyone in shaft and then that did end up happening, right? So we did end up trading lower
This is like a higher time from chart on the 15-minute
But the five minute did get tapped here then we did run to that buy side as you can see through this wick
And then from here, I said I still like longs longs are setting up nice
Reasoning for that is because we left equal highs, right?
So the market here is now going to still move because we want to seek liquidity equal highs is a very strong liquidity pool
So in this scenario, let's say we didn't leave equal highs and we just left, you know
Just and just a highlight looks like this, right? Let's say we did this
Then at this point then this would not have been like that good of a long right because we're targeting a high right here
We're targeting this high that already got swept by this side, right?
So it's gonna be not as strong as a liquidity pool versus you know
If we had something like this, but the reason I like this so much is because we left equal highs
So price ended up doing something
like this, okay
All right, so it looked like that on the lower time frame. Also. There's one thing I do want to say
And there's this huge misconception actually with equal highs and equal lows
You guys need to realize and we talked about this similar. It's similar with like the SMT video like SMT's SMT's
SMT's form all the damn time on the lower time frame. Same thing with equal highs and equal lows
But what you need to know is you need to focus like we said on SMT video at those significant liquidity pools
And the same thing applies with equal highs and equal lows if you have bro like a one-minute chart that looks like this
That looks like this where you have like
You know back-to-back equal highs candles. It's not gonna be as significant as if you had
Too higher time frame significant swing highs create equal highs, right?
so if this looks something more like
Bang bang and then we're trading lower and then we came back up and left equal highs at a strong liquidity pool
Then that's when you would really want to pay attention to equal highs
Not just because you had two stacked candles back-to-back on the one-minute chart create equal highs
No, because you created two significant highs that created equal highs. So
Just want to make that clear because you know, I see a lot of people
Really falsely, I guess explain and promote equal highs and equal lows
Online and we want to give you guys the true sauce and not give you any, you know
Stupid fucking information or concepts that aren't even valid
But yeah
Yeah, so
Again from there. I was saying long just saying I'm nice
Because price should seek out now this liquidity pool here
And we'll show you what those equal highs look on the Lord on the lower time frame because on the higher time frame
It looks like yeah, I think I had a screenshot though. Yeah, cuz that's a higher time. That's a 15-minute chart
Oh, yeah, I did actually. Okay, so from here. I
Have to actually have this opposite
Okay, so from here we did trade lower and we did run up take out those equal highs
So I know this is like you can't really see it that works
I'm on the five-minute time frame, but we did have equal highs here and then we did run up and take that
Okay. Now from here. I did say I was bearish right reasoning for this guys. Why should I be bearish here?
Well number one the market has done its job, right?
We seeked all really the liquidity that we could being this buy side here and then we seeked out these equal highs and then we
Had a fat run lower, right? So from here we are delivering from buy side and then what are we doing now?
We are disrespecting this bullish Peter, right?
So we had a bullish Peter right here on the five-minute and this thought got disrespected right price is fractal guys what we're doing
On the higher time frame and when I'm showing you on my daily bias on the higher time frame
How I actually found this daily bias to begin with I'm using that same framework on the lower time frame, right?
I'm thinking about price in the same exact way
Okay, and from here I then said price is looking bearish ASF right now, okay
I said I'm now looking for this sell side, right? Because what are we doing? We're clearly disrespecting bullish gaps
We're clearly respecting bearish gaps, right and we're very clearly trending lower, right?
There's I don't want you guys to over complicate this right price just looks like it's heading towards here
So that's where I'm shorting to it towards. Okay, as you can see and
From here I did say I want to see this send us lower
We have you know a bullish we have a change say delivery here with this order blocks
I want to see this send us lower. This could also trade up here send us lower and
Then at this point I said I want to take something like this
I want to have an inversion for value up here to then send us lower to short from and then wait notice this guys
Oh, yeah, here's the equal highs also. Yeah, no, then there's actually more equal highs before so
Right here we had equal highs
but we also had equal highs before with two significant highs and that also got ran and
Then we created three stacked highs above those ended up getting ran too
so same thing you see on the higher time frame you want to see on the lower time frame, but something I want to emphasize here is
Notice how just because we had this super impulse of candle down and we were and we were disrespecting
Bullish PDR raise we're not just gonna short at the bottom of this this goes back to rebalancing ranges, right?
So now in the lower time frame, we want to see this impulse candle down, which we showed you looked like
Sorry
Looked
Looked like this this impulse candle down. We want to see that range get rebalanced towards equilibrium
So then we can take shorts
So what happens you can clearly see here that price?
rebalances this leg to around equilibrium and then you would want to look from shorts from there because if price is gonna respect
EQ of this range
And start giving us confirmation the price wants to run lower then now you're
Validating that narrative that price wants to run so that's all side. So you can keep going. Yeah
Exactly, and then I did end up taking a short from that inversion for value got right there as you can see
We have trading up towards
We have trading up towards that right here and
Then we end up getting our short here and
Executions, I don't know what the fuck happened to say
I think I'm just accidentally closed and I had to reenter my position
but as you can see play out perfectly and
That's how I went from finding my bias to actually finding my entry
And it's pretty much utilizing all the same concepts guys
And it's asking myself the same exact questions that I'm asking myself on the higher time frame
Yeah, and I mean we can show you literally what this looks like on also like real time
So if we go over
Let's see a bit staticky, but like let's say let's go over like the most recent day of price action
We'll pop into the 30-minute chart here
I
Can delete these drawings, right? Yeah. So yeah, we'll delete these all check. It's that's everything
Yeah, so I'll delete these
and now if we go into the 30 minute time frame here, which I like to use because I
Can see how my previous sessions are trading?
We can go into a day like this, which was I think two days ago
And so let's look at this, right?
Let's start off all the way back here. So after London session. This is around 8 a.m
Pre-market we see that pre-market sweeps out Asia highs
So we take a significant liquidity pool in the higher time frame. Now. What do we notice this range is pretty imbalanced, right?
We have this really strong impulsive move. So now that we've seek liquidity
So now that we've seek liquidity, what are we most likely going to do?
We're most likely going to rebounce a range and want to hit like equilibrium of this
So if we fast-forward price here, we see now we've rebounced equilibrium. What happens?
So now we're respecting this bullish Petey Ray, but we're also opening up this bearish Petey Ray
So how do we confirm a narrative from here?
Well, we want to see what continues to be respected and what continues to be disrespected and you see going into like 930
We're sort of bouncing between Peter race. So when we have a scenario like this, we're like, oh fuck
Okay, we swept out Asia highs and we swept out London lows and we're respecting this 30-minute bullish and we're also respecting this 30-minute bearish
What do you think we're gonna do?
Nothing, we're gonna sit on our hands because we don't have a clear narrative of price
We don't really know where price is what we're gonna want to go. So
Ideally we tell it we set ourselves conditions, right? So if we look at like this bullish 30-minute
Right here. We have a bullish gap on the higher time frame and we have a bearish gap
So my thought process with something like this would be okay if price decides
To respect this 30-minute and then disrespect this bearish 30-minute. What's that gonna tell me? We're respecting bullish disrespecting bearish
Where are we gonna go most likely higher? But if we end up respecting this 30-minute and we disrespect
This bullish 30-minute. What can I expect price to seek this liquidity right here?
And so I would want to look for shorts to run all this LR and take out this final sell side as you can see
Eventually you have price
finally invalidate one of these levels and now what can we expect price end up running all this outside liquidity and you can see
Price ends up trending lower because we are disrespecting bullish respecting bearish and we're taking out this liquidity and we're running all this
And yeah, I mean that's practically putting it all together
This is like showing you a day where you start off relatively neutral and you go basing it off like higher time from conditions and
See if we're respecting bullish or disrespecting bearish
Yeah, I can also show you guys really quick the daily bias for this
And on the higher time frame, it's a little bit
might be a little bit easier for you guys to see right and
It's the same thing again. You want for your highest probability setups for price to be fractal, right?
So what I mean by that is you want us to team models inside of models, right?
So the same thing you saw on the 30-minute time frame, right where we're bouncing between this bearish gap here
Remember and then this bullish gap here. We're doing the same exact thing on the 4-hour, right?
So most likely when we disrespect this 4-hour gap, where can you expect price to go lower, right?
So the same thing you saw on the 30-minute time frames happening on the higher time frame, right?
And on this day I can kind of just show you guys what I had for a bias coming into this morning
I
Said we're delivering from this 4-hour busy disrespecting this bearish and I said is this a
First that was other day. It was this it was this day right there. Okay, right
So I did say if this ends up getting disrespected
Okay, so I said we're bouncing between these two gaps and I said I'm leaning more bearish, right?
Why because of everything that pal was talking about and everything was going on here. We're clearly respecting this gap
We also have an unfilled gap here
Okay, so it's it makes sense for price to move lower right to rebalance an inefficiency and for here
I said I need to see play it price close below this 4-hour if closed below expect the unfilled 4-hour
Okay, so if we close below this expect what this and then as you can see
On this day, you know respecting this bearish gap
We end up disrespecting this bullish gap right here. And then once we close below this
This is that confirmation that price wants to then head towards this low at minimum
Yeah, and also if you notice here
This is one of those days where we're seeking inefficiencies because we don't have like clear a southside liquidity a target here
But we do have a clear unfilled 4-hour gap below so we know that if this 4-hour bullish gap gets
Disrespected and this gets inverse and this one ends up being respected
Then what can we expect price to go towards this next inefficiency?
Which is this unfilled 4-hour and so that's really just like step-by-step how we build
Our biases and everything and I hope you're able to now like pair these things together
I think this has to be the sauciest bias, but yeah
But yeah, dude, it's not about predicting the market
It's about reacting to what it's telling you and so you slowly go from having an assumption to getting a confirmation of that assumption to then
finding your execution and
I don't need a yap any longer about this Blake doesn't need a yap any longer about this
This is genuinely everything you'll ever need to know about determining your bias
So I hope this made a lot of sense to you guys
And yeah, once again, we're sorry bro about putting a delay on the series, but we're gonna bang it out now
And yeah
We just wanted to show you guys a little bit about who Blake and I are because all we ever did was give you a like
Lore video, but we didn't really show you our lifestyle outside of trading and we don't just want to be like traders to you guys
We also want to be like regular people
But yeah, I mean this was our ICT for dummies episode 10 on daily bias and
Share this shit with your friends bro. Show people. This is really how you determine your bias
We are quite literally giving you every sauce you need not
Know one that you find online is gonna be this transparent and show you this level of information
That's just a reality and that's not me being like egotistical
We just genuinely like have always wanted people to know exactly how we go about it, bro
We've been fucking crushing in the markets for a long time consistently pulling in six figure months
I mean recently it's been insane. I've won like the last I don't even know fucking
16 out of like 18 trades and I'm showing you this guys literally right in front of your face
I literally predict the market every single day for you guys in the daily bias and our premium discord
And we're also showing you this. Yeah, but you don't you don't need you don't need a fucking you don't need the disagree
You don't you don't need shit at the end of the day. You just need to be like
willing to put the time to learn so if you can watch this video take notes on it and start applying it and like go
through previous day bros and and like
Use it use our thought process to build your narrative you're gonna realize that your bias is right all the time
But this is only you know one piece of the puzzle then
Figure out those lower time frame drawn liquidity is getting those entries is also another thing
But we really did show you everything that you need in this video
And this was a main focus on bias, but we even went into like lower time frame drawn liquidity's went into
Entries and like we said, this is all fractal. So the same thing we're looking on the higher time frame
We're looking for on the lower time frame. And yeah, we're gonna keep pushing out some gnarly gnarly ass
Videos like this sort of just free flowing through shit. You can see that this video is completely, you know unedited
And this is what we do every single day that being said we fucking love you guys
And thank you so much for watching our ICT for dummies episode 10 on daily bias and we'll catch you
What was that? What you didn't even know saw no song. No nothing. It was depressing
Give me a beat
Wait
I hear you're doing here
Bitch I'm psychopedia race disrespecting respecting if we respect bears then I'm bearish bias
Hey, I feel like Adele
Sucking on your balls. Oh my god
Bitch I feel like ICT I got these cell side imbalances. I'm filling it up. Yeah, wait
Mmm
Bitch I feel like that's my draw. I'm hitting that liquidity. Oh, bitch. I feel like an inefficiency. I'm feeling that shit
I don't think it's any of our days. Yeah, it's not our days. Give me one more just one more try
Mmm
Yeah
Hey, mmm higher time frame
Wow, wow, wow, wow guys
Where we do the first try we're actually so good. We actually do this first try. This is usually so much better
I like you nervous. Yeah, why am I so nervous bro? What the fuck in already?
Yeah, mmm
Yeah
On the lower time for bitch, I find a fair value gap if I see that big booty bitch
You know, I'm finna slap executing on the one to five minute
You already know that I'm always fucking stingin bitch. I'm catching all these trades bitch. I'm always getting laid
18 fucking wins bitch, you know, I'm getting paid and I do a crazy bitch none this shit Fugazi
Patty in Blake, we don't do this shit. We lazy. Um, uh
Didn't make any sense. Yeah left-curve gang
Determine my bias. Yeah Asian, so I eat rice
How do you on the show I do right now how do you end it I do right now